I'm not here to murder bend the knee and
join me or refuse and die you need to
find a way to make a listen stands in
our way
[Music]
run saw the night king and his army
marching towards East watcher
but things are coming hey guys feet here
okay this is going to be my Game of
Thrones Season seven episode 5 trailer
breakdown we did get the official
trailer right after the episode so I'm
gonna break it down frame by frame looks
pretty interesting all the way around of
course this is going to be spoilery so
don't watch if you don't want to know
what's coming up in the next episode we
open with a shot of the battlefield
after the field of fire 2.0 we see that
Daenerys is talking to a group of the
soldiers that are left behind after she
says I'm not here to murder bend the
knee and join me or refuse and die we
see that her choice of words isn't to
Tyrians liking by the look on his face
still he's standing by her side though
and this is really a much different tone
that we've seen her take in the past
here she's not painting herself as some
liberating force
she's just pointing out what they've
already seen that she's incredibly
powerful with her dragon and saying that
she'll kill anyone who doesn't follow
her we have to imagine that these
soldiers will join her ranks as
conscripts but they are very different
than her unsullied and Dothraki in they
didn't choose her we'll talk about that
more later but can't overlook it at this
point we also see the draft drogon is
alive and well perhaps a little worse
from his shot you know getting hurt
there but he does seem to be recovering
from his wounds so nobody has to worry
about him dying anytime soon I would say
we then panned across the battlefield
and get a shot of the destruction that's
been left behind not much will remain of
anything there we can see that much even
in this brief shot we then see beerus
and tyrion talking and Varys says to
Tyrion you need to find a way to make
her listen there's no response but we
can hear concern that he has and we know
that this is obviously the same concern
that we saw antarians face just a few
moments
when he was standing in front of those
soldier we then see a shot of Daenerys
standing in front of the sunset with
drogon he has his head up and he looks
to be okay we hear a voiceover from
Cersei saying whatever stands in our way
we will defeat it there's a montage of
after we see Daenerys looking like a
conqueror in that shot we see the dragon
flying overhead John's standing in a
field there at Dragonstone seeing
Daenerys return and then we see drug on
land right in front of him as Cersei
finishes what she was saying we see
Qyburn was there that's who she was
talking to and he nods in agreement drug
on looks aggressive whenever he's
standing in front of John with Daenerys
on his back but we don't know how that's
gonna end up playing out really from
what we see here we hear John's voice
come in he says that bran saw the night
king and his army marching towards East
Watch and we see that he's in the map
room at Dragonstone talking to Daenerys
explaining the situation so I'm guessing
he got a raven from bran and Winterfell
and he's explaining what's happening up
north we see a cut of Ravens taking off
from Winterfell I'm hoping that this is
like brans little army of Ravens to go
north where he's gonna spy on everything
that's going on up there we see bran
with his eyes rolled back in his head we
can imagine that he's probably there by
the Hartree at Winterfell then we see
the Ravens again swooping down to see
the numbers of this gigantic white army
that the knight King has we see what
looks like the night king and his men
the other White Walkers in the middle of
this whole thing we hear Davos say bad
things are coming and from what we see
with the Ravens flying over high
overhead he's not wrong he's definitely
not wrong
so an interesting trailer with
everything that we know is coming from
the original trailers and everything
else it was a little confusing as to
what would go down in Episode five we
can expect that Episode six will be the
big battle north of the wall that we've
seen so many shots of being that it's
the penultimate episode that's usually
where the big battle happens and we've
had our field of fire at this point so
we're gonna see an ice themed battle
north of the wall of course John is
still in Dragonstone in this trailer not
sure if he'll stay there for the whole
episode of episode 5 but we'll have to
wait and see how that all goes down I
think the biggest thing that when you
have just watched episode 4 and you're
sort of taking everything in the biggest
thing about this trailer is Daenerys
they're talking to those soldiers do you
remember if she took off and took things
into her own hands doing the fire and
blood approach what she executed pretty
well but this does change the
perspective on all these people that
she's asking to come into the fold with
her of course giving them only the
option of dying or fighting they're
gonna probably pick fighting but this is
a lot different than whenever she would
show up at a city and free the slaves
over in Essos that shot of the destroyed
Caravan is also very interesting and I
talked about this in my other videos
about episode 4 but she's really kind of
put herself in a position by destroying
all of that stuff that was taken away
from the farmers and the reach of course
she wanted to win that battle decisively
but to me it doesn't make a lot of sense
that she destroyed all of that food now
whether that food would have went to
people or to the armies it's kind of
immaterial since it is gone but that's
that shot of the battlefield is kind of
what we're gonna have to expect is going
to happen in Westeros at this point it's
gonna be a lot of pain and suffering
involved with what just went down plus
we get at the end we see that [ __ ] is
about to start to go off in the north
when is coming I mean people are in for
some bad stuff as Davos pointed out some
of the things that we didn't see here
for one we did not see Jamie and we
don't know what sir she's talking to
talking about there some people were
worried that Jamie would die because
he's wearing armor and he's sinking like
a stone at the end of the last episode I
don't think that's the case at all I
don't think he'll die bran was there and
a lot of other people saw that happen
but where is he
how would he get away is he gonna be
captured is that going to be the thing
that leads to Circe's inevitable
insanity and trying to get him back we
really don't know there's nothing here
to give us an indication of that we also
don't see any more Winterfell or the
north besides what bran is seeing north
of the wall so we have no clue as to
what Arya and Sansa and Littlefinger are
up to but we do see the brands on the
case he's looking in on the movements of
the night king he knows where he's at
and where his army looks like and he is
somehow or other communicating with Jon
which most likely they sent a raven it's
interesting to see the Varys and Tyrion
are there to hopefully keep Daenerys
from going off the chain completely so
also pretty exciting to see her landing
back at Dragonstone with Jon right in
front of the dragon obviously we're
hoping that the Dragons will take to Jon
in one way or another and he'll end up
being a rider although I can't say that
we see much of that move forward if at
all here so yeah it has the makings of a
good episode it'll be a setup I'm sure
for Jon heading north for Cersei making
her counter move - what just happened
there at the field of fire 2.0 so there
I would say that this didn't really give
a lot away this trailer but it said a
lot of things up it should be exciting
to watch I'll be making a couple more
bonus videos leading up to the episodes
like I did last week in the week before
so we'll get into some of these things a
little more deeply before episode 5
comes out let me know in the comments
what you're thinking about what you
think all
this stuff means as far as what's gonna
happen in Episode five what did you
think was the biggest moment that they
revealed here what do you think is going
on in the other parts of the country
that we didn't see and what do you think
is gonna happen when drug on lands
they're right in front of John do you
think we're gonna move the John
dragonrider idea I've had it all or is
this just a tease make sure you like the
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel I'm doing a full schedule
of Game of Thrones videos so make sure
after you subscribe you hit the
notification bell so you can know when
they come out follow me on twitter and
my other social media accounts to keep
up with my other stuff and thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon I'm not
here to murder bend the knee and join me
or refuse and die
you need to find a way to make a listen
whatever stands in our way
[Music]
run saw the night king and his army
marching towards East watcher
about things are coming